all right welcome back to the Rich Eisen
show and jordiz work for many many years
in Sports Illustrated and now a weekly
columnist for the athletic he's written
eight books New York Times bestselling
author eight times eight books for
football for a buck the crazy rise and
crazier demise of the USFL the author
Jeff Pearlman here on the show how are
you Jeff and well what do you have there
on your life a gift for you here well
you can't what do you have this is a
t-shirt yes and is the logo is the San
Antonio gunslingers and I it's the
greatest worst logo in pro football
it's sort of his yeah it's like woody on
crack is so now one of the two players
there like was that this to you I
appreciate that a nice Laureen San
Antonio gunslingers shirt and it says
what big paper on the back so uh one of
their star players one of the stars the
USFL was this guy Greg fields his name
was his nickname was big paper uh-huh I
was with the LA Express jon heder was a
head coach
mne cut big paper and big paper reached
across the dust and punched him in the
face
and the team ended up hiring Liberace
security guard because he was calling
death threats to the to the coach long
story but um he ended up with the
gunslingers and he followed the owner of
the gunslingers home with a baseball bat
after he stopped paying players and
walked away with 17,000 in cash Wow
I told you there'd be good stories above
this one where is big paper today do we
know yeah we do because no one could
find him but my son Emmett is nine years
old and we tracked him down we had two
addresses me my 9 your kid big paper who
bit hit his coat to the bay or
threatened his coach yes wound up at a
Sacramento shopping mall eating Cold
Stone Creamery in a food court having a
great conversation about the USFL so you
you and your son yeah track down big
paper bad parenting moment son
son let's go track down a man who once
followed an owner with a baseball bat
and got seventeen thousand dollars in
cash did you tell your son big paper
stories did he knew all about big favor
and we actually I hate to say it two
addresses one of them was deep in the
projects and the other was not in the
rep but I had him walking all over it so
you know we found him hey we got father
and son stuff they'll never forget I
don't never forget and you know it's
amazing to me just again reading stories
like this and seeing the pee I mean Jim
Kelly Steve Young Reggie White Doug
Flutie
Herschel Walker Mike Rozier all people
Sam Mills right who played in the USFL
just just for starters and the coaches
too that were there as well like
legitimate serious
big-time coaches who are either
previously head coaches in the league or
became head coaches George Allen Chuck
Fairbanks Jim Mora on and on and on you
came around yeah how did this not work
how did the USFL not work Jeff I mean
the first year is 83 which it was a they
lost a lot of money but the idea was
it's gonna be spring football and you're
gonna lose money at the beginning but
it's a start-up and that's what's gonna
happen and to be honest this isn't a
political statement but this is what
happened Donald Trump bought the New
Jersey generals heading into the second
season and in the lead-up to buying it
he said I love the USFL yosef I was a
great I love this league as soon as he
gets the generals we need to move to
fall this is embarrassing blah blah blah
he held a he had a secret meeting in the
Pierre hotel with Pete Rozelle the NFL
Commissioner at the time paid for the
suite and said to him I don't care about
the USFL I want an NFL franchise what do
I have to do to get in the NFL there's a
offering to throw the recive under the
bus if a many NFL team and Rozelle said
to him straight up as long as I'm the
Commissioner of this league as long as
my family has anything to do this league
you would never be a part of the NFL but
he told him to his face or them to his
face in a meeting at the Pierre hotel
and Trump you know say say we want the
guys resilient yeah yes you know he does
not stop that's for sure he convinced
the other owners in USFL that follow the
TV deal that would be waiting for them
and fall would be massive and he lied
and said that he had meetings with all
these fall executives of TV executives
and they were really excited about it
and he was he was the owner of the
biggest franchise in the USFL Washington
had kind of failed la it kind of found
Chico go kind of failed New York they
had a contract with the ESPN and ABC
they had to have a New York franchise so
Trump had an you know overvalued sort of
presence hmm he convinced the other
owners to move to fall they famously
sued the NFL he guaranteed the other
owners they would win the lawsuit he'd
guarantee they would win and they did
they want $1 times 3 what was the little
one 1.3 billion they went $3 okay so
let's put that aside for a quick second
so
do you think now again this is not this
is nothing to do with politics he'll
zero zero to do with politics do you
think that any of the NFL bashing that
the president is currently doing was
born out of the moment in that Pierrot
tell me anything you just told me about
that the NFL said you will never be part
of this league Oh I mean it's
preposterous I mean you try buying the
Baltimore Colts in nineteen eighty
eighty and found he met with Pete
Rozelle failed he said he would sue the
league failed try buying the Buffalo
Bills failed
put in a half-baked effort to get the
New England Patriots failed for guy who
hates the NFL he has made repeated
efforts to get in the NFL I never think
that's kind of telling also when he was
the owner of the generals and this has
been docking he did business during the
national anthem he would be on college
during the national there's nothing
wrong with I'm sure both of us have
worked in press boxes during the anthem
where you have a call or something it
happens hmm but the whole idea that this
is about patriotism is to me just
laughable football for a buck the crazy
rise and crazier demise of the USFL the
author Jeff Perlman here but that said
he Trump said we will win a lawsuit and
he did but did anybody see coming the
possibility that the damages that they
would receive would be one singular
American dollar that gets troubled
because of the rule the check still
exists I know that where is that check
right now right now I think it's at the
pro football Fame because they have a
USFL exhibit right now it's usually in a
bank vault in Memphis cuz well number
two Donnelly was a guy named Steve
Ehrhardt and he got the check and he
keeps it no he never cashed in though
never cashed it it's great a three
dollar check it was I think it's three
dollars and 76 cents to be precise why
did it get on why why was it only one
dollar Oh
so basically what happened is um because
if it was a serious amount of money USFL
was right what it's absolutely survived
so basically what happened is this trial
goes on and what they were suing the NFL
for what they were saying is the NFL was
monopolizing television and the NFL was
plotting to destroy the USFL both those
things were 100% true the NFL was
monopolizing faul faul TV monopolizing
fall TV and they did have these
documents talking about what do we need
to do to kill this league cuz if you
remember euros Laval got three straight
Heisman Trophy winners
Herschel Walker Mike Rozier Doug Flutie
they stole Doug Williams from the Tampa
Bay Buccaneers they stole Brian Sipe
they got Herschel Walker
like it was on and on and on when
stole no I stole stole is the wrong word
like Doug Williams is a perfect example
here's the Tampa Bay Buccaneer
quarterback I think it was the 48th
highest-paid quarterback in the NFL at
the time there was no one unrestricted
free agency there was nowhere to go
you call her house he hated and you over
house refused to trade him you know
where to go well the Oklahoma outlaws
come along and say we'll pay your money
to come here
great the interval viewed this awe as an
attack on the NFL like they saw it
strictly isn't this they are attacking
us they're making this hard on us
salaries are skyrocketing because we
have to match so the end of I was going
out of their way to kill off the USFL
they want a gun and they have this
lawsuit and the jury decides you are
right
the USFL is correct the NFL is
monopolizing TV yes I mean the NFL's
monopolizing TV the NFL is going out of
its way to kill the USFL but and I
interviewed one of the jurors about the
trial which just it was fascinating but
the USFL is his own worst enemy and
moving to fall stupid they had a they
hired an outside research group to
present to the they paid $600,000 for
marketing group to present league owners
about fall versus spring yeah and this
woman gave this long presentation to all
the USFL owners gathered around the
table and said the dumbest thing you can
do is move to fall and Donald Trump was
the first one to stand up and say you're
full of crap we need to move to fall
right now it was this preposterous so
when you interviewed the juror why did
they come up with $1 why did they do
that
well she said they had to at the end of
it was guilty but the NFL wasn't didn't
actually do anything to cause you a
USFL's ultimate flight so they gave her
a reward to them because they were right
and guilty but they just decide to give
the minimum old reward but that's like
you know hey I'm gonna you know I I
appreciate this you know I get it like I
don't appreciate the service but I know
I got a tip you here's a here's ten
cents that's basically what it was
honestly that's basically and the best
part is Donald Trump is sitting in the
courtroom and John Mayer was the owner
of the Giants at that point or sure
still and he's sitting next to Donald
Trump and John Mara opens up a snoo
jacket
pulls out his wallet takes out a dollar
bill and hands it to Trump like the
greatest moment ever so no wonder he
loves bashing the NFL I mean this is the
ultimate revenge play isn't it
I mean if you're talking about you know
30 years in the making
absurdly rich people battling it out Oh
Maisie it is crazy
Jeff Perlman here on the Rich Eisen
shows so what what is your if I you've
already told me a story about big paper
yeah what is your favorite story from
the book if you could use one of the
many I mean the the Chicago blitz and
the Arizona Wranglers were traded for
each other after the first season so the
blitz were george allen's team mm-hmm
and they have like a lot of they're like
Tim Spencer and Greg Landry and Tim
Wright and they'd good players and the
Wranglers were this crappy team in
Arizona that I think they finished four
in 14 it was an 18 game season but the
owner of the Chicago blitz was a guy
named Ted Dietrich who lived in Arizona
and he got tired of making nine three
hour flights
via charter jet to Chicago so he had the
teams traded for each other so all the
players in Chicago were traded for all
the players in Arizona and the Blitz
became the Wranglers and the brailers
became the Blitz as as players said to
me like my kids had to drop out of
school and move to Arizona my wife had
to quit her job because this guy didn't
want to fly three hours so it's it's
it's a bit the best solution ever boy
yeah the owner of the new owner of the
Chicago blitz is a guy named James
Hoffman two games into the season he's
walking off the field the new bullets
are terrible their coaches Marv levy
Marva levy thought he was getting the
good team until he showed up nobody told
him the teams are traded oh my god the
owner it's two games in the owners
walking off the field with this guy a
former bear named named Dan jiggets oh
he remembers all that he does reports
luck rays and shenanigans play for the
Blitz sure Dan jackets and the owner of
the Blitz are walking off the field and
Hoffman the owner says yeah I'm so I'm
out of here and Jake is like oh where
you going
he's like no no no I'm out of here I'm
done with this I don't wanna do this
anymore
and Jake is just like why he's like yeah
I'm done I don't own this team anymore
he literally dumped the team on the side
of the road and the USFL had to take
over like he just decided one day I
don't worry when I own a USFL team
anymore I think I'm done and the Blitz
her own and the GM
the USFL immediately hired all their
high paid staffers the GM of the blitz
locks himself in his office calls every
media guy in the area and goes it's
crazy what's going on here it's like
non-stop everybody like the best do you
want to write a book on this it's
unbelievable the stories that it is
crazy that it this didn't happen like 50
60 we're not talking about the AFL on
the NFL this happened in the 80s man and
so the equivalent would be lets say the
XFL would call levy on bail right now
yeah
right like you wanna play really like
you're you're not being paid by the
steelers you are not under contract why
don't we pay you an absurd amount of
money now wouldn't you say the NFL would
suddenly go hold on a second yeah right
and try and so you you can't kind of
blame the NFL for trying to destroy
competition I mean the interesting one
is Hershel did you remember I feel like
a lot of people now don't realize he was
iconic like Hershel Walker coming out of
Georgia wasn't just the latest Heisman
Trophy winner he was larger than life
and he was a junior and the other foul
didn't take juniors at that time so he
called he called the USFL and said I
want to come out of Georgia you know he
had a poor family right to feel Georgia
I want to come out and when they signed
Herschel Walker actually the Dallas
Cowboys called Herschel Walker's agent
right before he signed with the generals
and said we think we can get around the
swine of Hell thing we don't want you
going to the USFL and Herschel Walker
said it's too late I already agreed but
it was it was a giant sort of grenade
thrown to the NFL that they signed a
junior coming out of college didn't do
it at that time mmm so that was war this
is war well I just was going through my
head as well the XFL would not sign
Le'Veon Bell you know why because he's
he's had an arrest you know in there and
they're they're not gonna take those
people who have been at all foul of the
law and put them in pads and helmets
it's gonna be the cleanly that's the
good guys
well the Alliance as you know is that
they are lockstep with the NFL but I
think they want to be in in league with
the NF every bombing Charlie ever saw
has been you know everyone in the NFL
knows him through his dad for all those
years they got they got Polian and
Polamalu and others furrier rights Perot
I mean that so they're I think they
would like to be in a way a minor league
for smart way to go a course yeah of
course why wouldn't you want to be in
business with with the people who are
you know the professional football
I guess industry that's
I always think like it's smart for them
to be able to she have a quarterback in
home aha who signed by the 49ers the
USFL would have fought that to the death
to me the team in Omaha the best thing
they can do is this you were press
relief in a release and have a press
conference saying you saw him here and
now you're gonna see him there
absolutely and also in the NFL with the
practice schedules the way that they are
and the offseason the way that it is now
scheduled where you can't get your hands
on somebody till the middle of April
with no European league there you need
to get reps and and and the number of
coaches that say they cannot develop
skilled position players like
quarterbacks anymore there might be a
need for the NFL to have another league
I agree in a spring they're not paying
for yeah right right
labor it's great great to have you here
football for a buck the crazy rise and
crazier demise of the USFL Jeff Pearlman
that's just a slice of what is here in
this book thanks for coming on this is a
lot of fun go by it today the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience